so we're in the home stretch let's see
if part c is true and i'm running out of
real estate so let me let me copy and
paste it actually actually maybe i could
do it over here to the left i had some
doodles here let me clear those out
so let's see if we can do it over here
to the left part c so we have this
determinant and it's claiming that it
equals zero so we have to see if that's
true and so we can actually try to
multiply these out and see if anything
interesting happens
but we could even better leverage some
of the algebra that we've already done
for part a
for part a in part a we figured out
we figured out that z minus z1
z minus z1 is equal to t times z2 minus
z1 is equal to t times
z2 minus z1 so this thing right over
here this is the same thing as t times
z2 minus z1 and the reason why that's
interesting is i have a z2 minus z1 here
so i'm starting to have similar things
and then this thing over here so if i
take the conjugate of each of these if i
take the conjugate of each of these the
conjugate of z minus the conjugate of z1
this is going to be equal to t times the
conjugate of z2 minus the conjugate of
z1 and i know that because when i do
this i'm swapping all of the signs on
the imaginary parts of the complex
numbers so if you were to go through
this entire process just swapping the
imaginary parts of the complex number
the end result would have its imaginary
parts swapped and that's exactly what we
have over here we have the imaginary
parts swapped over here so if you want
to work it out set this equal to a plus
bi or set this equal to a1 plus b1 you
can work it out but i think it's a
pretty intuitive idea that we're just
making all of the
we're just swapping the signs on all of
the imaginary parts of each of these
complex numbers now with this said this
determinant becomes pretty simple
this becomes t
times z2 minus z
1. this becomes t
times
t times the conjugate of z2
minus z1
this down here is z2 minus z1 and then
this over here is the conjugate of z2
minus z1 and so what is this determinant
it's going to be this times this so it's
t times z2 minus z1
times
z2 minus z1 times the conjugate of those
so it's that times that
minus minus this times this so minus
t
z2 z1 z2 minus z1 times the conjugate of
z2 minus the conjugate of z1 now this is
exactly equal to this these things are
obviously going to cancel out and we're
clearly going to get 0. so c is also
true so the correct answers to this
original problem
the correct answers were a c and d